hey guys how's it going today in my
kitchen we've got Sarah deechi Sarah
peach it rhymes with peachy because it
solves a problem known as how to
pronounce well there's a secret but
never actually tasted a peach before
what does have to like I've honestly
been living away
don't you happen but today we're going
to resolve that because we're going to
make something which I actually really
love peach cobbler which you know
nothing about I don't and on her Channel
I was surprised Rio no I bought you some
key this oh and these are real peaches
not real peaches oh my gosh and you got
peach look crow if I did have one we're
gonna have a great taste test on Sara's
channel check it out you know something
you you tell me your opinion on this but
what is your opinion on desserts that
involve fruit I always feel like it's
cheating because I'm like I associate
fruit with healthy things well there is
a cup of sugar that we're going to be
putting into this don't worry because it
is not healthy at all and if you can
pancake batter this is going to be super
easy so what we're gonna do is make it
so you don't cook I don't cook either
the most I cook is about mac and cheese
oh that's good there's three steps heat
oven stir together fake so we messed the
shop which is definitely possible all my
fault if that happens I've messed up way
simpler things so step one we're gonna
eat preheat the oven to 375 I'm going to
open up as I've enjoyed but 350 400 for
can't do math so do you think this is
enough pancake mix we got here just do
it's two times because your head that's
insane
1/2 cup butter or margarine melted so
we're gonna melt that first yep so put
this in here yes you know what I just I
can hear wash pants yes dude I isn't
that like step 1 it is okay I've been
washing my hands all day no I've
definitely got that covered so I'm gonna
melt the butter
oh gosh I'm Justine has a knife I feel
like I need to take a step back here
maybe - are we putting D's in Chile if
you want to do strawberry I don't know I
mean I got a thing that people model no
my mom would be so proud of the kickin
off with sugar in genomics okay I'm
doing a terrible job no yeah oh my good
look I'm thinking like it's looking like
wow let me get a knife or a fork
oh that's doing it it's just look don't
hold the balls yeah oh god helper
teamwork makes the dream work
yep bam bam does it meant to be like
clumsy like that everywhere doing
something right yeah they're going to be
like a michael clumping mixture yeah at
least I think that's good alright I need
to have all of our fingers we do can you
believe it I can Oh what look there's no
sister together the sugar and peaches
and have you heard the song play
presidents of the United States peaches
peaches come from that can to put there
by who
a man in a factory downtown have you
heard this one we are have not probably
because this whole
[Music]
I am learning so many things I think
peaches is it means something bad I feel
like it needs something bad it's
probably something not good I mean uh oh
well oh this is boring yeah Chris not
saying analyst all he said the peaches
was written about a girl he once had a
crush on he allegedly wrote the song
after sitting under a peach tree she had
in her yard while waiting for her to
arrive
this song was out 1996 boy I was born in
1994 shut up get on bye guys I'll see
you later just been released on a
cassette
what is a cassette though yeah okay now
we got that out of the way I don't want
to do something real quick because I'm
not sure stuff oh yeah you shouldn't
it's time to risking damage control 1986
a great year for music I'm gonna have to
send you a pilot you all right there's
blue look at this I just want to show
you how little I know if you don't
manage we know I know we have to strain
this but I don't have a strainer but
what I do have tough it'll work let me
wash it fresh
[Music]
ah so we shouldn't eat wheat and stir in
the butter after the biscuit mix milk
and that milk we need milk looking
really high missed that how much milk do
we need oh man
maybe I should look for Justine am i
right guys
yeah wait wait so milk isn't in the list
of ingredient why had suddenly
instruction wait yes it is is it yep
oh I did increase my strainer really
where does the milk go
does it go in here so this quick mix
milk and nutmeg I think we're making a
peach Chris all right I don't let just
do let's just make something happen I'm
not sure like maybe we can just so
forget about the milk shake
I'm sure we don't need milk out here oh
[Music]
my gosh
and you want me to hook it up because
it's fully healthy that don't really
grow that's all really disgusting oh
you're going to ruin my $30 shoes oh hi
maybe I should just throw it in there
yeah okay yeah I will just do that all
right all them in look that's right area
my first impression of peaches is not
very good well I think I might have
everything to do mama I just wash my
hands so like at this point I didn't
matter so this how you guys make peach
cobbler this is literally booth this
most sinful recipe that I've ever seen
in my entire life and I don't know how
this happened
oh my god oh my gosh so on this topic
what is your biggest fail well you've
done with your cooking this is up there
tonight I dropped my sister's wedding
cake that I was making commitment no no
that was a good fail catching something
on fire in my old kitchen we're talking
about fires have you ever use a fire
extinguisher I have not huh I think
that's a good thing
probably but I think everyone should try
to use one just to know what it feels
like because it's quite surprising yeah
and you did it did that make more of a
mess than the fire did oh I I had to
burn the house down
this is because it was such a mess all
right so do you think we should adjust
our time in the oven or do you think
it's the same come here good boy oh man
come on good boy sit school you're still
brewing I have to show you his best
trick please hold this
Starbucks CJ that ago just slipped up
right here Texas time to DJ time to CJ
coupe will come on time to DJ good boy
but time to DJ come on pivot right up
ones and twos I'm Sara thank you
huggbees I can get good lovin we go whoo
okay all right
50 to 60 minutes it says Wow I think
we'll just check on it periodically and
see what happens I have absolutely no
idea what to expect I think it'll just
be more crispy instead of which I'm okay
with that I'm not a person for gooeyness
yeah I'm good
let's see what's going on in here it's
been how long do you think it's been all
right
like 40 minutes maybe 40 minutes it
seems to be bubbling that doesn't look
like we can eat it well yeah I think we
might need like a gyro or something like
it's supposed to be doing this it looks
it truly does look like a inch on a
catchable yeah hey Jenna what did you
think this Liz come here Jenna it looks
like we'll just cheese and we'll use
mashed potatoes keep the magic am i
thinking is really first one who tastes
this you would eat everything that's in
there don't worry if you make it
I got a phone call and then forgot about
my food so we're just gonna take it out
it's boiling it looks suspect I'm not
sure about this kid look out I don't
know what to burn you
Oh guys this doesn't look very good it's
boiling smell it it's not like yeah now
you know I don't know villain what do
you smell cinnamon oh yeah mmm it's
peach cobbler oh it's just where's the
beach ball don't touch you're gonna hurt
yourself so it was peach cobbler didn't
turn into peach crisp and then it turned
into enchilada casserole become
nationally oohs yeah Matt it's compiling
this is definitely like it when you
think of like crisp this is the opposite
of Chris this looks like when I made
sure oh this is what Jerusalem yeah
better than what hurt your house in
London so when I said I was making
churros with a party this looks
disgusting
this is not a churro this is a mistake
so I obviously need to get some peach
like we gotta let this cool off I want
actually boiling I'm Chris penis to it
well there's no not here yeah me more
peach it's the broth Oh hot okay yeah
don't touch it don't defecate in five
come on this day is taking us all very
hot boiling
Oh mm-hmm see how much nutmeg well
that's your problem you know what I
think there's too much drama in this is
good don't like I remember we sit on the
milk good time finding it I need to get
a little another day sir why is it just
oil it like it's not or just another
butter we're doing a lot of butter in it
Christ Irving butter so now starting to
spot nicely look you not minute what oh
why I'm here cries oh God
oh is that closet well hell I happen
still the overall taste after I stop
crying like I like it but it's not
terrible sting - yeah it feels like I
have Jolly Rancher stuck to my teeth
well not what peach cobbler is for the
face legs not that you would know what's
happening I'm unsure of what I did wrong
I mean there's a few things that I think
that we I think we know exactly what we
did wrong the cup of milk that we didn't
put in and why the order of things we
did details really important when baking
I know wait this was a good lesson to
all the directions kids we try we try
and we did we did those to be fair if
you bother beginning I guess I didn't
read an expression
she she loved uncute rest you can't well
guys that's it this was peach cobbler
with Sarah DC whose name rhymes with
peachy go check out the video music open
her channel because he tracked well I've
tried peaches before but she tried
teaches for the first time crazy
it wasn't
thank you for having me yeah because I'm
no more truly an honor
yeah hmm you've got your blue suit I
take this home with me yes take a look
at inbox in New York good until next
time see you guys later let me know what
you'd like to see me make next
and the venerians plus it's very hot
though it's very hot you want me to be
hurt are you gonna buy
[Music]
hahaha